Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Bendy and the Ink Machine.
And welcome back to the
final chapter of this twisted story of a Disney gone wrong.(horribly, horribly gone wrong)
Now, I don't know how this is gonna end but in the last chapter
We actually started getting into some really interesting things about the universe about how everything is made of ink
Everything and what happens when a society starts to rely on ink entirely and what does that do?
and how does it blur the reality between
Life and arts and all of that metaphysical bullshit going on there.
Oh. Is that so you guys sing me to sleep here?
I know you're just lulling me into a false sense of security
Hello!
Hmm. So this is the this is the actual cartoon come to life
And that means that the last thing that we saw
Henry..
Um Henry, this is the first time, this is the first time that we've had a voice ever. (Not true.)
I mean ever, we didn't have a voice before but something absolutely wrong about that ha Boris
Hey, buddy, how you doing? Whoa, okay, that's a little threatening. Ha ha ha
Hey Boris, what are you doing Boris?
We, you and I, you and I, we got along unless I was just some other version of you that didn't really make any sense
You must be got ink for me. Oh good hi. Oh
That's ok. I've been scarfing down ink since the day I got here. Ok
Hi Boris, hey, how you doing?
ok. That's a little rude
(boris is jealous)
Ok, well, you know, I like the other Boris, the one with X's for eyes, so it was probably a horrible mangled doll
That was harvested for ink organs. Look
Man, Boris what happened to us?
Uh... What else am I watching?
Ok
Uh-huh
My eyes.
My special eyes!
Is Boris gonna knock this on the floor too?
Oh
*nervous giggles*
Maybe
That's prob..
That's so sweet!
Oh, wait. Wait, no. Wait. No no. No I saw a message that you would leave me for dead
.Don't sashay away from me.
All right then. At least I got a magic looking glass that's gonna help me in some way shape or form or not
That was stupid, Tom
You dumb Tom (Don't insult, Tom!)
You dumbass
So stupid! You're not Boris!
Hello. I'm here *does some weird shit*
Okay, alright, hey, haha
Okay, again with the threatening thwapping of the axe. I don't like that, Tom. What happened to Boris?
I guess Boris got turned into a horrible muscled monstrosity
Come on
Yeah, Tom you big dumb dumb ass use your axe you fool
*imitating Tom* Look, uh me me no how to do
Oh what? no! wait! no! hang on! wait!
Um Tom you have an axe it's wood you axe?
Okay
Locate the gent pipe
If I could have gotten out here this whole time
There's always hope take the spoon Oh God. Oh
Don't go through the door escape trust her. It's inside the vault. Whoa
Whoa
You draw bootifully, thank you. Thank you. Who's talking? take the spoon!
oh X3
This is here the whole time you mean I didn't have to shit in a bucket. Oh
Come on, this is here. Oh
Look inside you'll need this. Okay. Let me just stick my hand bleep. And unless you're talking about the hole. Oh, I
Here I was, ready to go elbow deep in the shit hole that is this toilet. Oh
Nice nice. All right. Well
You see how Boris or Tom could have just easily flunked these away
Tommy piece of crap! Tom you piece of poop! Tom you and it's I guess that's true
She will leave me for dead, but she didn't want to, it wasn't malicious. I guess. It's fine Oh
Well ain't this just sweet here. Hello fishy! Wong!
Wang!
Doodle!
Whomping! Are these fish drawn too?
Ma'am, is everything drowning here? Is anything actually alive? Is anything actually real?
No, ooh
Scary oh
Hi, oh, we get grabbed womp womp
hey now, no need for that you sack of ink
I Don't need that. I'm trying to explore here. I'm trying to see some secrets.
That was a secret
Follow me. Okay, that's not much of a secret. Okay.
I hear voices whispering at me from the darkness. I'm not sure if that's a good thing. Probably.
oh
ah
no no no no
*gibberish*
You don't need to do none of that to me. Starting off with a weird wampie combat, but I guess that's okay
I mean over time in this game. Yeah
Over time in this game. I think it became less and less about being a psychological horror game
I'm more of like the interesting, like universe that it encompassed and once it started embracing that I mean the last one
the last chapter had some scary moments and I really appreciated that but I think like overall it's because this game is
Actually a really - there's something in the river - a really interesting universe and it's something that you want to explore
It can be a mixture of both and I've got a bad feeling about this. Oh
Well, goodbye, I'm sure that wasn't supposed to happen that my boat that a boat. Can I get on the boat?
Danger! Keep out
Okay here I go then
*RAMBLING*
*MORE RAMBLING*
*ME BEING A MARKIPLIER AGAIN*
Oh(realise 4 minutes ago )
I
Didn't know I had to do it twice
What kind of?
why was
Was the point of that just to make me look stupid? Well you succeeded. Alright, fine. now I'm here. Alright
Follow the Ink River. I don't know
i Don't know why there needs to be an Ink River. I think a river of ink is a little much
I think that we could get by without it a river of ink but alas I don't make the decisions here. I
Just try my best to not screw up
I've got a bad feeling about this
(my spider sense a tingling)
Oh
This looks like oh
I don't want to know what's stuck in the paddle wheel. Oh
I DONT WANT KNOW IS STUCK!!THATS BIG BORISS......OH MYGODD
OH SHIT
I'm gonna get get out. Get out. Get out. Get out. I
Didn't know I was that close to doom. Oh, I gotta go through the inky butthole again God
Just in the realm of thoughts not THOTS - uh, hi
Okay back into the butthole River
All right. Well everyone ignore the fact that I screwed up there. I am an idiot. So what's to be surprised here?
Okay
What is the big-ass hand in the river? Is that Boris?
Because I got a funny feeling everything comes down to Boris being horribly horribly horribly mangled
into horrible horrible shapes
And everything is horrible in this game
The gameplay has gotten better. I'll give it that
I mean also I gotta remember. I need to be a little bit forgiving about the game because at its core
It's an indie game
made by a very small team maybe even the original was made just by one person or a small team of people and it's
Expanded into something that's really caught on and that's because the idea at its core is in fact good
The idea behind it is captivating. It's something that you can't look away from. OH Okay. I'm..Im not gonna okay
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no we're going for it
I ain't gonna wait around for no giant hand to come claw me. Alright, but it's good
I don't want to know I don't want to look behind me
I don't want to know I'm gonna assume that it was something nice like a rainbow or babies. Just shoot now ever
I don't know why that would be nice, but I just imagine that and now I'm scared
No. Thank you X3 go please. I don't know why the flashing light is necessary
Hmm also, there's something very childlike about the whole disney-like aspect of it
I mean, it's it's horrifying when you really think about but it is that kind of like
Childlike sense of terror and not really like the body horror that you would normally be used to and yet
We are in a river filled with Pope. Come on
Try not to die to a giant hand that's gonna claw the shit out of me
But it's it's fascinating it's honestly truly fascinating from start to finish
It is fascinating and I like that I like that la. Oh god, how many times is gonna get gunked-up?
I would have thought that this stuff was supposed to be for designed for this
Yeah, whatever make it a coincident
That's no good at all I
Like the tuba guy farting in my ear back there it's real nice helps me keep time regular intervals
Okay, Oh
Again, how much farther I gotta go with this thing?
Can't be much farther. How long would it need me to go through here?
There's Boris. I don't know why bori
ohhhhhhhh
Um, I
Okay
We're just gonna ignore the fact that there's an Ink person right there
And we're gonna walk into this
Futurama sewer esque area where I'm assuming Ink people live
Okay, goodbye guess I'm not going back that way. Sorry everybody in this shantytown that I
just ruined the transportation system of
This bill me for that later. I guess it's time to believe he will set us free. The Creator lied to us you bring death
Well, I suppose maybe you might be right
Hello
Anybody there? Okay. No
All right. Well, nobody wants to come out and talk to me
That's fine. Once people now fallen into despair not monsters
Are these the former employees? Oh
(oh hi Sammy)
Oh
Okay
All right, what do you want it what oh,
Okay, all right how good God you have an axe I have a Wooper
How is this fair and why is my blood Ink? I might like one of you okay, well
And back in the butthole again. What was I supposed to run away? I didn't have anywhere to run man
All right time for round two. Yeah, ouch. I'm gonna smack the shit out of you
I'm gonna smack your ink all over the place. I don't like your face. I don't like your foot
Okay party
Oh, I can block, I for.. no, I can't block
Cannot block. How did I beat? How did I beat anything before in this game? Am I just dumb here?
I mean don't answer that cuz obviously the answer is no I'm smart, but
It
Seems a little
Seems a little difficult. Maybe I should just run. That's what
He's real tough
Okay. Can I go the way he came in? Oh I can oh
But to what end? Oh but to what end all but to what end. How about this? No
Okay, oh well you shy because you're ugly you're attacking other people because you uggo. well come on now you ain't that ugly
Okay. Well the
( Boris be like nahh you go to sleep boii)
Hi
Wow, thank you
Yeah, I think oh, okay
Huh? How we fight? Why are we fighting anybody? Why do we need to fight? I like the ax. Thanks for the ax.
That's nice. Hey, do I need to do anything here? Can you do all the work that these?
Hi-yah. Oh god. I'm losing again. Look at this. Well, what a surprise. I'm bad at the combat in this game
Who would have thought you?
stupid piles of poopy
This was a peaceful town for the fishermen then I walked in and everybody hates me. Oh god. Oh god. Oh god
You not can you not?
You guys help?
Yeah, I've never seen this many either whoa whoa, whoa big guy big I'd begun no no no no no
No, have I been gradually the grudgingly one Tom's respect as well
Okay
We get him oh
Yeah, oh yeah, oh
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, ow, ow, I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die. No not today now God in the butthole again
Did anyone play test this game? I can't be the only one that's as bad at this
I cannot be the only one that dis bad at this because you can't run can't do nothin. It's just fine
It's whatever, you know, it's fine
Look at this. Look at this from the far
Because you can't sprint when you have this. Okay? Well, I guess I need to help out here probably
You guys don't seem capable anything Oh
Oh
Pumpkins no helmets. I'm getting some helmets
My Fucking God
This can't be an intended part of this. I'm sorry. Listen, you guys have to forgive me
I'm trying my best here. It's not that I'm bad it's that the balance is
marginally off
Mal dababneh mal balance. It's just a little bit off. This is a little bit off and I keep getting surrounded
They keep sneaking up behind me ha
ha no ha ha
Ha ha ha ha. There's no defense mechanism. Okay, or or I won't hit you. Whatever
Come on oh if you meant what's so it's so floaty. It's so impossible to judge where your axe is actually gonna head
The one thing I said about this game from the very beginning. Is that why did it need it?
Didn't why didn't need integrated combat mechanics, but ok. Here we go
Melee, why can't they give me an ain't gun? Draw me up a gun or an artist?
Can I deal with this my own way which is gone?
Oh
My god, this is so many of them
How long is this gonna go on for and how many times am I gonna return to the butthole realm? Here's another one
There's no way anybody can get through this on the first try. There's no way(actually the Video Games News was the one to due in a first try will replaying ch 5)
Anybody can I'm it's just pissing me off because they're making me look bad
But I bet anybody that's playing this part. He's going through the whole same endeavoured that I'm going through trying their best
But getting banished back to the butthole realm not today, not again
Here we go again, I guess
More more more more more 100 more
Okay, you weren't done yet. Okay fine
Anymore, is that it? Can we be done? Are we done now?
Yeah, I would agree
Why would I know the way?
Dude. This used to be an animation studio. I don't even know what's going on here
You would deserve a Swonk on the nose but I'm gonna forgive you about that one. We're gonna go this way
Hmm. I don't know why I'm suddenly slower than I used to be. Are we gonna be separated?
Is this how we get separated?
Yep, Oh
Best if we stick together, huh? Whoo
Okay, but no. All right. No, we're not gonna stick together Nah. There's a load of crap
Now was a load of crap from the get-go
All right, but now we're separated. So please stay
In the spooky part of it. Oh god a pooping chamber. Oh my god
I've been waiting for one of these for a long time. Oh
Sweet Enki relief I didn't even have a toilet in that jail cell the holding it this whole time
All right. What have we got two goos?
Hello, ah
Okay
Oh
Huh drain the passage find the missing pipes. Oh
All right. Well, I'll do that another scavenger hunt
the biggest part of this game's game mechanics
Okay Thomas Connor I could barely hear you over the sound of the music. Oh, oh Boris Boris
Is that you buddy?  I think I found an easter egg a cute adorable
Wittle easter egg
Anyone up there? No. Oh now the music's done
Oh now the music's done when I didn't need the music to be done. Now now the music's done. Okay, whatever fine
Sure, okay
C-can I set this here pipe. I
Need one of these Bend(y)s, but I need some ink to make into it I think
Oh, I did have a voice before what am I talking about
I thought I didn't have a voice before but then again, I'm an idiot. Of course. We had a voice before I don't remember anything
okay administration is opening up for some reason the game got a lot more floaty as soon as I open that
Okay guys weird thing I
Hit that button. And then the mouse sensitivity went way high why?
Would the mouse sensitivity go higher?
when I why why would
Why would that?
Why would that do that?
The I'm dead serious the mouse sensitivity shot up as soon as I opened that that is beyond bizarre, okay vault
Well, I guess I should I wasn't sure what I was hearing there
So I didn't even know that there was a credible threat, but okay better stay out of sight then which way you coming buddy
Yeah, that's what I thought you stupid idiot. You dumb doof
I don't know who put you together, but that was just as dumb as you. Yeah, you stupid fool
ain't gonna give me
(Please close the door.)
(The "dumb doof" could always come in)
(Close it!!!!)
Okay, Joey drew. Whatever you say Joey Drew. We all love you Joey Drew.
From the tip of your head to the tip of your show. We love Joey Drew. Okay, you ain't see nothing, huh?
stupid bobblehead looking mother humper (Ok, I'm just paranoid)
over here
The creator lied to us. Yeah. Well, what else is new?
Alright
Okay, I
Think this is just a fancy way around so that I don't get snuck in on them. Okay, that's a hidey hole
That's good to know
Is it just me or is the mouse sensitivity creeping back up again, which would be the weirdest thing? Okay
Nothing here. I don't exactly know what I'm looking for. I'm assuming I'm looking for material with which to
Eventually build the pieces that I need, but I don't know exactly where they're going to be
I guess I just keep wandering and stop worrying about the little things
Hmm nice wall piece
Okay
So this entire office is also built out of ink but I mean that much is obvious at this point
I don't think I can even be surprised anymore. What will and will not be made out of ink?
Cuz it all is. The answer is everything
Yeah
I'mma wait for that to go by. I'm gonna go through here and then behind it because that's the only way I haven't come
Hello you stupid idiot
You dumb fool don't even know when I'm sneak AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH But okay that was not expected
Okay. Oh, you're gonna be right here aren't you? Oh you dumb fool. Oh you incompetent goof
Okay. Well, I'll just run by you then. I guess you're not very fast. All right. Oh, you're kind of fast
Okay, whatever. I'm gonna keep going and if I die I die
It looks like I'm about to die
We're going here close the door. They'll never
Know the guys I think they know hang on. I'm gonna hide in the poop hole
Where'd he go welp
Wingus dingus let's get out of here. We got no clue one way or another
All right
Aha, okay, well two plus two equals you stuffed your employees into ink monsters and gave them
fucking again with your
bullshit
Good lord. What's wrong with you? You stupid piece of poop. is it cuz I called you dumb and ugly?
I'll take back both of them and I call you
incredibly
Unintelligent and not good face. How's that get better? You like that better?
Whatever, I guess I'll try to sneak
Alright, can I take this I need a pipe
Okay, I
Skipped by a few offices, but I'll come by on the way back to try to get him anything in the trash can no
Hope I
Just walk right on by stupid
Man, there's a lot of them for some reason. It's like they're on my scent and they know where I am and they
Kind of want to get a piece of me
WELP. NEVER MIND.
Well, good god
How am I supposed to be able to get to where I need to go?
If you guys are just gonna be a bunch of douches about this. I'm never gonna be able to make any progress
You stupid piece of poop or I'm going in that room. You do not turn around. Okay, good. Ah
Shit nothing in here
Alright, I'm gonna go in that room. You guys don't turn around. I
Don't the blinking light is all about but blinking line is usually round suppose it go right? Well nothing here Oh,
Where'd he go? Okay
And this place big?
This is a circle, I think it's a circle. I think this is just a circle
Yeah, it's a circle. There we go. Okay office of Joey Drew. That's the first time that I've seen his office. Hello
Okay, but that's good cuz that sounds like where I need to be
Slurp that down feels good. Oh
Now we're talking
Don't do it Suzy Suzy, don't do it Oh
Suzy don't do it. No, it's a trap Suzy. Joey Drew might be a little bit crazy
Joey Drew might not know what he's talking about
Just go that way and keep God. Yes, right. He's stupid watch your step. Can I take this I
Got some ink I don't know if this is enough ink, but I've got some ink
Got some stinky ink, okay
Good, maybe I can get out. Oh, this is where that would have looped to. Okay, that's good to know. Okay, maybe I can get
Eyes on another on the way back, but it looks like I might be cut off here
Okay, let's just see. Okay, there's
An opening. Oh, they might spot me. Ah
They didn't spot me
They did not spot me. Okay, so where was the machine it was right here. So if I pop this bad boy in
Crank out one of these. I
Think I need a curvy one. I think I need one more. There was another path that I could have gone
What (HIDEHIDEHIDE)
Oh
(Bendy's gonna getcha)
(Get in the poop station, (I think that's what it's called))
Okay, I
Guess everything is fine. Oh
God, how many do I need?
Okay, well I
Guess I just gotta go back. Maybe I can get more from the same place over and over again know what I gotta do. I
Guess that's what I gotta do. So here I go. Oh I didn't get this one. Did I get this one? I think I guess
Oh Wally, why did you record
Your crime for everybody to hear
Doesn't that seem a little bit incriminating to you don't anything that might be okay. Oh
Oh
Oh we can I get another yes, I can. Okay, Wow. Hey
not in the butthole zone again, uh
God someone please reenact this with the guy from Twilight Zone just you have now entered the battle zone
This is a place where reality doesn't make it. Oh
Wait a minute, I
May have found myself a shortcut. I may find myself a good
Old-fashioned shorty Cuddy. I
may have found myself a
shortcut I
Think I did I may have found myself. Oh
Okay, how do I there we go
Kachunk. All right one more. I may have found myself Oh
shortycut
All right. Well
You don't care about nothing. Do you?
How did everybody else lock on target to me so quickly but you guys are just bumbling idiots the can't even be focused on one
thing at a time
Almost makes me feel foolish for dying to you in the first place. All right, I call this one the butthole shortcut
Cuz watch this oh
Not your head
Not your big ugly head
And then you just walk into the butthole zone and you just kind of like stick your hand out
and you scrape some of the butthole ink on the way out and then next thing you know
you've got a bunch butthole in your hand and
Baby you got a stew going instead of a stew it's a horrible inky butthole
Instead of an inky butthole its system nightmare there you're gonna need years of therapy to
If I even get out of here in the first place
I don't think therapy's gonna even remotely change anything about this because I'm pretty sure my interiors are all inked at this point
Anyway, here we go
YAAAAAAAAAAA
Don't know why that was set up to be like that but okay
of course, you know the decontamination zone into the vault with ink
Right
Okay, there we go
I Just had to do that. You guys know what it's like
I Had to I had no choice. Okay, so something broke in or out of this vault
That's the first obvious thing
but why?
Why would there be giant pipes of ink flowing into the wall? This seems like it seems like bad security right here
I've got a funny feeling about this
Hi
Yeah
That's convenient
Very convenient
Oh
Yeah
Hell yeah
No more hunting for gears Tom. You're all right in my book
You get a little rub on your noggin you little pet Tom you are
Just a dreamboat. Okay. Alright
Also side note don't mess with Tom because Tom punch your chest into your ass. Wait a minute
Wait a minute
Wait
wait a minute
Are we back like towards the beginning of the game?
CHAPTER 1
Why? why should we not?
Ohhhh
Hiiiii
'LA LA's mixed in with 'Hey Hey Hey's
that don't look so good. that thing don't look good at all. Oh, that's some kind of gangly
Oh you got like some problem with your spine there?
Alright, anyway, see ya. I'm supposed to be real quiet. So have a nice day. Goodbye
Death
Yep, confirmed okay death has been confirmed. Okay, good. Alright
Is this the ink machine?
Tom punch the oceans
I can't see you
You're all blur
not always. not always a reason
Good you got a halo Tom you got an arm
All right. Well, I guess I'm going alone
again
You guys are abandoning me and it's not fine. It's not cool in any way shape or form. So here I go
wa da dee dee da da leely
Well, did they? Throw me your ax. CLUNK All right. Thank you
I miss Boris
I'm guessing this must be the official Ink Machine. I mean, I know in Chapter one. There was the Ink Machine
in there that was originally pumping out the ink but
I'm guessing this might actually be THE ink machine
Well, you guys look like a whole bunch of fun, why are you looking away you shy oh and hey
Tom and/or Boris, how you doing?
What a lovely lovely lovely place or a throne
Is this a throne? I'm gonna guess it's a throne a quite bondagy throne, but nonetheless
Hi hello, how you doing
grumbly
It was you got a grumbly in your - Oh, that's a big hand
Whew, that's a strong grabber. Yeah, are those your strangling hands? Oh
Who's a big boy?
OHH, Who's a big boy?
Who's a big boy, I love thumbnail moments, ow, okay. Thank you
Oh well, uh, Oh, what where am I? Oh
Oh well, um
To who this I am outmatched in every way shape or form
I'll just take a breather in the butthole dimension cuz I have no idea what you want from me. Hey
I think I was supposed to dodge
If I had to guess I think this the main point here is that I'm supposed to dodge
Whoa, well, he's just having a good time. He's just a scampering
Okay, I think there might be a pattern to his running
Maybe yeah, there's a pattern. Okay, so he doesn't come this way
He was how he's gonna go left to right across in front of me
No
Yep. Yes, then he goes that way
Okay, there's a switch. I like flipping switches. I
don't know what they do, but I got
It wait a minute
as soon as he goes
Gonna go zooming back this way and he's gonna come right through there. Yeah, okay
We got the pattern a little bit down
So I just got to stay out of trouble for as long as I can. Oh
Shit yeah
Well, I mean, he's just he's having a good old time. What is this dude? I
have no idea
Oh
It opened the door
pass handy
All right. Where does this door go? Oh, I need to find I see. Okay. This is gonna be the door out
I just got to find all of the switches
it's just too terribly bad cuz
This is a matter of avoiding. Uh
Avoiding his stampede. That's not so bad. Okay, there's another one
Okay
So
Where would another be is another
Okay, I got to imagine that they're all opening the same doors
It's funny because he's he's really not that bad. He's just a cuddly guy that likes to run he's just scampering
I just interrupted his exercise hour. That's all really is
Okay, I'm gonna take a gander
He's gonna come barreling. Oh no, it's open. Okay. Well, I guess that was all of them
Easy enough. See you buddy
She on the other side
Have a good day
Catch you on the next life.
I guess
All right, oh I got troll oh no, I didn't Oh,
Who's laughing now Wow
And I don't know always laughing. I haven't seen any more secrets from this thing, but this looks like a final arena type. Whatever
All right, let's do it. I mean I was never laughing in the first place
I'm not really the type to laugh in the face of danger
I'm more detective just buckle over and just sob uncontrollably in the face of danger. Ah
Here we go
Found it. The one inconspicuous. Oh, hey, how's it going there now you don't you want to play? Okay
That's a little oh, all right, I didn't do that. Oh, excuse me. There's a box in my right
Hey, I didn't know that that's what I was supposed to do, but apparently it was so I'm doing good
Hey, come on. Hey stupid you big dumb goof
You missed you're supposed to hit this thing is stupid my headache hit what you gonna do
Okay, wait, this is a problem
Okay, you already broke that one. You didn't need to break it again, you big dumb stupid
What
What happened Oh
What what what happened
Why did everything go black
That was weird. Okay. I'm not gonna really read into it too much
Okay back on the third. Hey, the chair is mine if this chair shares mine. Oh, that was all I needed to do
Why didn't you oh hey, uh
Hello. Oh
Yeah, yeah movie time. Come on. Let's watch a movie
Yeah yeah movie time don't worry about it, man OH NO ...THE END
RAHHHHHHH
And then he's gone
Anybody in the pooper?
Scary
Very scary
Big Boris, oh, wow. It's all the games. Okay. Well, that's kind of cool
oh
(Back again in hell)
Wait(Please someone make a remix)
Hang on hold up. Take a second. Hold it. Hey
Wait up
Hold on
so this
whole place
Was in this old guy's back y....yyard
Okay, I'm cool. That's fine. All right
Don't get it. That's okay. I don't know why everything is so wrong
Boris went a little wrong, but that's all right Joe J Thomas. All right
I don't understand anything that happened here, but there is one more chance and I will see it soon
There's one more thing in the end of this game
to be seen
Even if I'm very confused even if I'm incredibly incredibly confused at this entire operation within this guy's back room
somehow(shook)
is that the ink machine?
(confused by the liitle girl voice)
I Am very confused and I don't understand anything
Anything at all?
Something don't add up here. I don't know
What is happening in this game?
I'm really confused
Cuz I really am. I'm really honestly truly trying to piece it together exactly what the story cuz obviously that
that last sequence, that last sentence that, "tell me another one, uncle Joey" like
All of this, I think the point it's trying to make is that all this is just ideas come to life in ink
Like that's whole thing, these stories
These shows, this movie, this whole universe. They're all part of stories and
in a way them coming to life is no different than them coming to life in an animation in a in a video or in
an animation in anything like that, but at the same time
(mark is becoming a game theory)
It's a little bit confusing
And I'm wondering what the connection is between everything because what it like what is the point that they're trying to make?
What is the what is the end result out of this, right? Are you just trying to keep it open-ended?
So open-ended it'd be like anything's possible with the power of imagination
Were you trying to say that like this is the this is the end result of a man
so obsessed with his creations that he actually did bring them to life in a perverted quest for
Building his own Empire and it burned around him
but then again like that whole intro sequence of like go check out the old workshop and then
Going there you have unlocked the seeing tool in all previous chapters
Well, I'm not gonna go through the whole game with the seeing tool even though that would be cool
But I'm not gonna do that, but I am gonna go to the archives
so we go here and
We go. They did also they remade the first chapter
I will say that but I'm gonna go to the archives here because I want to know what is
The dealio with this.
Welcome to the archives. Bendy and the Ink Machine began when the developer
Cartoonist known as The Meatly experimented with bringing a sketch 2d style into a 3d world
After turning the idea into a horror game,
Chapter One of the game was created in a little under a week with programmer friend Mike Mood and released on February 10th  in 2017
much to their surprise, it struck a chord with global indie gamers almost overnight
the Meatly and Mike Mood decided to drop all of the projects to work on Bendy and tell the most unique ink story.
The entire game was completed a chapter at a time in a year and a half by a small but dedicated group of indie developers
Although the concept and story remained as originally intended, the game changed over development as characters and models were refined from their early
Thrown-together versions. This archive is a sneak peek behind the scenes at that process
Interesting, I'm gonna do this more of a narrated guiding style. Ooh, okay. Let's start from left to right
We will love the art. I love the whole art of this place. Oh my
Goodness gracious. Oh
Oh
Oh my oh my oh my oh my concept bendy
This is the first version of bendy ever modeled in the earliest concepts bendy was much smaller and cuter with a face that split open
To reveal a terrifying mouth. I love that.
I love that entirely. I love that completely, that is terrifying. They should have used that in some way, shape or form
they should have used that because that is
Horrifying alpha bendy. Okay. I remember this one
This is the original game use design of ink bendy from the earliest version of chapter 1
It is jokingly referred to as "bird poop with a smile" among the development team
yeah, I could kind of see that but it does have a very like
Interesting silhouette, it looks very muscular without actually being overly bulky and that's kind of a weird threatening stance to it
I actually don't like the design of the final boss very much. It's just very um,
I don't know, it's nonsensical in a way and it just didn't seem very threatening. Whereas the other one was slight and I
Don't know just seemed like it was a morphus and actually could be anything whereas that is just a big muscle monster
Which is something that I don't really like in horror things
Beta Bendy. This was inked Bendy's
Form until the release of chapter 4. At that time, the game received a major visual upgrade and the key title character got a new
Model as well
Okay, pretty cool ink bendy ink bendy as we know him today although similar to beta bendy
This upgraded version was remodelled enhanced with a higher polygon count and given new ink effects
Okay. Now this I like this I really like cuz it's got this weird bony skeletal structure and the face is obviously leering
and more peeking out from underneath ink, but at the same time I
I gotta go with this one I really do
I really like that one or this one
As opposed to this one wins one is nice with a higher poly count and everything but there's something about this one. That's just like
Unnaturally disturbing in its silhouette whereas this one just seems like I'm a monster
It looks like one of the imps from doom. Whereas this one just seems like I'm trying to be hue like hello fellow human
I am bendy
You know in the way ya be spending
Bendis horrific final form in chapter 5 pulled away from the cartoon facade and revealed the demon within yeah
I kind of see what you were going for and like in static. It's kind of cool
But at the same time, I don't know. It just feels like it detracts from the actual horror element of it
I feel like when a lot of things go overly muscular and too big
You know with a lot of like sharp teeth and shark style
like I I get that it's it the idea is scary but the execution
often falls flat because - a funny little legs here, but that's not the point like it just it's less horrific and more just like
I'm a brute. I'm a big dumb brute. Whereas this one and is inherently more interesting
I think that's his personally though beta searcher early in development with just a few weeks to create chapter 2 the beta searchers were designed
In record time before being fully retooled later on they were the first fighting enemies encounter in the game hate you
Hate you very much. I didn't even notice the mouth there. That's interesting
That's a final search err. Ok hate you also. I love these guys, though
Hey I love, even though they're dumb and their AI wasn't too good, I like him. (back to the searcher) far more robust in appearance
They were smoother with better ink effects and a more human appearance
I'll take your word for that one. Beta Sammy with his first appearance in chapter 2, fan favorite
Sammy Lawrence became a terrifyingly entertaining character. When his slim build was deemed not threatening enough
He was redesigned and given a better skeletal rig for more advanced emanation. Ah
Again, I disagree
I
I don't think final Sammy Sammy Lawrence's final form came complete with a bulked up stature and more powerful limbs
The mad songwriter may finally get notice now, at least by fans( Sammy got finally notice by his senpai). See I disagree I
Don't think that adding muscles or bulking them up in any way is more interesting to them
I think that the the overalls are modelled better and fit his form a little better
But I don't think bulking him up inherently makes him more threatening. I think it just makes him seem more like a more like a
1920s like rail worker or something like that someone working in the iron the iron departments
The thing is if he's a musician, he doesn't look like a musician
I feel like there's nothing even to give him any sort of personality to this
I don't think muscles is the right way to go to give him personality
It's an inherently interesting thing where this guy goes mad and like takes on the face of bendy
But at the same time I feel like there could be a different direction
Not that I have anything off the top of my head, but you know
I'm kind of thought of the original BioShock you remember like the the
Photographer that like actually like cast the corpses of the people like in different ways the weird elegance that he had
I feel like the like if this is the sound designer and all the music form of it
like it's like the musicians not gonna be bulked up like a musician's gonna be fancy a
Musician's gonna try to retain the fanciness in some way, shape or form, but then that again that's just my opinion
I don't even know about you
There's no message about you. Hello, so
Which one of these was the actual human?
That was turned into the monster
I think this one must have been the human that was turned into the monster and this one's actually
Just the character brought to life. You know what I mean? There's Tom. Ah
Betta, Boris Papa papa papa. Oh
Hi papa
Yeah, Papa was the original name of the character that eventually became Boris the wolf. This version was released with chapter 1
He was quickly refined into the boris
We know of today with the releases of chapter 2 who I loved don't know who Tom is screw Tom
Boris the wolf a friend to the end was designed using various references for cartoons of the
1920s a blend of West Coast and East Coast animation styles the silent and supportive wolf won over the hearts of many
Although at times. He was a headache for the development team due to be as AI taking a mind of its own during production
Yeah, but that's what made him cute Oh
Big Boris brute Boris. Now, this is now this is a
Good example of brute like meeting a horror style taking something that you once loved and turning it into a brute
I think that kind of works better than taking something you hate and turning it into a brute like
Alice Angel's monstrosity. Brute Boris was one of the biggest surprises of chapter 4
His design was roughly based on the Frankenstein monster
But with a more unfinished appearance Alice took parts from within him and substituted thing that his body is rapidly rejected
Yeah
I can kind of see that see a lot of the elements of
What what you take from before is is made in a horrified way. See the other one. It's not enhanced by its bulk
The bulkiness of it doesn't enhance any horror of it because it doesn't make it twisted in any way
It just bulks it out. This one takes something that was adorable and cute and retains enough of the features of its original cuteness
So that you can see the perversion that happened to it. And I think that's a good thing about it
The head is still exactly the same shape
you can kind of get the sense of the overalls and now they're stretching and ripping at the seams like this bone jutting out of
This leg here
that's kind of cool and the weird the weird way like the juxtaposition of the hands and stuff and
The sense of it kinda is is good in a way because you can see what you've lost
And I think that's really neat about it
um
Lastly here. We have the ink machine before a major visual upgrade
This version of the ink machine was the one the game used in the game much of the machine's
Iconic fan loved design was translated into the final version
Yeah
There's the ink machine. Alright. Oh
This guy, I love that now. That was a cool boss. That was a really cool boss
I think a little like the gameplay could have used some tweaking but it was still really cool
Oh, here we go
The butcher game the Piper, Striker and Fisher made up the butcher gang. Interestingly,
The Ink corrupted versions of the characters were designed first and then were reverse engineered back into their more friendly family friendly cartoon forms
There's nothing not family-friendly about this. What's not family-friendly about these lovely lovely things
anyway, all criticisms that I have are not like
Not to be taken like in any way sort of like with expert opinion. These are just my opinions
Those are just what I would do if I had the ability to do it
But I don't have the ability to do it because I am not necessarily an artist. I am just a player of games
I've never made one myself
But that is just my idea behind it. But this has been bendy and the ink machine
I liked it. I really do. I have a lot of problems with the gameplay
But I've never ever had a problem with this story with the idea behind I,t the world, the environment. I think it's very original
I think it's really cool to see. I think it brings a lot to the table and I think there's a lot to be learned
From the experience and I can't wait to see what they make next whatever this company does
They've hit it really big with a lot of success. Ooh, that's scary
Now if it actually had eyes like that it would have been a lot scarier. Oh my god, that's terrifying
Oh, I hate that. But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this adventure into bendy and the ink machine and
Let me know what you thought down the comments below. if you want to play this for yourself and see the secrets of the mirror
Throughout the beginning of the game
You can play the game. I'll put a link in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching always remember to support the indie developers who make these great games that we can all love and
and Enjoy and thank you all so much again. And as always I will see you in the next video
Bye-bye